hi i'm zack snyder and today i'm doing
the wired
auto complete interview
i do not google myself uh googling
myself would be a dangerous activity
all right so uh what zack snyder
doing now oh and i answer it i'm google
uh well i'm hanging out at the house
with my kids
doing school washing my cars that's
pretty much
it all right i'm gonna do another one
what is zack snyder
directing style wow directing is like
the managing of an idea right so if you
have an idea
you have to manage the actors
and the photography and stuff i have a
pretty casual style with my
people i work with because i just tend
to like human beings
and i want them to be happy
so i don't torture him too much that's
kind of how i do it
let's try another one of these things oh
i ripped it so you can't see
what is zack snyder known for right now
i'm known for um justice league i
suppose people's
exact snyder justice league i i did that
to myself
unfortunately people would think i was
known for slow motion i like slow motion
i don't really like slow motion that
much
if you do a percentage of slow motion in
my movies i would think you'd find that
it's
one percent or something like that i i
know someone's analyzing it right now
and they're gonna
say no it's 50 so yeah i don't know what
i'm known for
what is zack snyder's justice league
rated for rated r4
uh i think it's rated r for violence and
nudity no not nudity that would be cool
you know the ratings board
doesn't like it when superhero movies
are violent so um second card
here we go is zack snyder nice
no he's a jackass i mean can you say
that you are nice
i don't know that people are allowed to
say that i think you'd have to ask
someone
but i like to think that i'm relatively
nice is zack snyder
related to scott snyder sadly no
because he's a genius but no we're not
related
his zack snyder and auteur
[Laughter]
i think i'm gonna leave that up to the
audience to decide
is zack snyder
a packer fan yes zack snyder's a huge
packer fan
i'm the same age as the lombardi trophy
i was born in the first super bowl year
and therefore
i am kind of a personification
of the super bowl pretty much grew up in
green bay
and my dad you know went to the ice bowl
game i would love to make a vince
lombardi movie at some point
that's a fact how zack snyder
how did zack snyder become a director
it's a good question well i started
making movies when i was around 11 years
old i saw a movie called star wars i
don't know if you're familiar with it
my mom bought me a movie camera super a
movie camera she started shooting movies
and then when i got into high school i
would make about a movie a year with my
friends a
big movie we'd make a bunch of smaller
movies but i always make one big project
a year
we did like kind of a my version of
apocalypse now
and then i did another black and white
film and i went to film school and then
yeah how is zack snyder
how is zack snyder cut different i don't
know
because i never saw the theatrical
version of justice league so
i don't know how it's different but
i'm sure it is how to watch
zack snyder how to watch the snyder cut
there's a lot of different ways you can
watch it it's divided into chapters so
of course you can watch it piece by
piece
i say the best way to watch it is with
an intermission after
all the king's horses which is one of
the chapters about two hours and 20
minutes
into the movie this chapter will come up
you pause it you go to the bathroom you
get your chips or whatever you're eating
and you watch the rest of the movie so
that's how i would do it
i appreciate everyone's personal styles
when it comes to watching the movie
how to watch zack snyder army of the
dead well
first of all netflix or in a theater for
a week before it comes out
you're never going to want to stop it
it's too insane
so yeah i would say you just sit and
enjoy okay
why zack snyder why zack snyder is best
at what okay
well that's just a great search if
someone's doing that search why zack
snyder is famous
i i'm not sure and weirdly i was getting
a copy on the way down here and i had my
mascot and everything
and this girl leaned out of the car and
she goes my dad said you look like zack
snyder and i said i am zack snyder and
she was like we just saw justice league
it's awesome
and i was like you're nerds by the way
just so you know if you recognize me
with a mask on you're you're you're
nerds
but that's cool i love nerds so it's
cool
why zack snyder tattoos why do i have
tattoos
they're all sort of related to my kids
and my family
so you know that's kind of cliche
but it's fun
why is zack snyder zombies i think the
great thing about zombies is like
they're very sort of post-modern it's
like what if the monster
was just society you know and that's
kind of fun so
who zack snyder so this is a i'm getting
it now i'm getting it now
each one's slightly different who is
zack snyder's
wife oh deborah snyder a genius producer
and manager of my insanity
oh no i revealed two at once i won't
look at that one
who is zack snyder it's kind of
everything we've been talking about
at the end of this whole thing you can
kind of glue it together and figure out
kind of what i'm about
who is the villain in zack snyder's
justice league
who's the real villain it's darkseid
really
i mean i think you could get a sense
that steppenwolf is the bad guy but he's
also kind of
likable in a weird way you know he's
just he's just trying to get home
who is zack snyder his favorite director
that's a really good question you know
probably john borman
is my favorite director i'm a huge fan a
talented filmmaker
who tells like really mythic stories and
i'm into that so
does zack snyder so does zack snyder
let's not tear it off
have instagram i do not have an
instagram
and i'll tell you why full disclosure uh
that i am
a um brand ambassador of vero
which is the social media platform that
i uh prefer
although i do have a twitter account
it's probably this next question
does zack snyder
have a brother well yes i had a brother
he
sadly passed away when i was in my teens
but he was a huge influence on me
in the high school i went to in the
boarding school i went to there was a
sam snyder award
amazing guy so um yes does zack snyder
write comics write comics i have not
written a comic
i should so maybe after this i'll
go write a comic note to self
write a comic and then does zack snyder
like marvel i do like marvel i like
marvel movies and i like marvel comics
the hulk has always been one of my
favorites forever
and iron man the answer is yes i do like
marvel
okay i made a mess
you